foreign
I think this one turned out better
[Music]
holy king so I figured might as well
it's so tiny and cute
[Music]
we're just walking the buggies you can
see they're starting to bloom
and it smells really nice too I'm so
excited finally cherry blossom
all right
[Music]
good morning I'm taking the shinkansen
this morning to go to visit Chris in
Sunday we have a bunch of stuff planned
it should be really fun
foreign
[Music]
one more month until they remove the
mask mandate it's so annoying
why is there always a vacuum
every time
all right
stumbling upon this
that's pretty though
that's not bad
I almost died yeah we found this abandon
theme park
but Chris is being paranoid and I don't
understand why but it doesn't either
uh it's like that one scene do you
remember when you look out the window
[Laughter]
he's the best in the business
a thousand people used to live here
that was a ghost town
can you turn it on for me
just hit switch
I'm ready
this thing is about the collapse any
second I don't know why I'm pretty sure
you were bigger than the very horse
you're sitting on
[Music]
foreign
that's my private jet right there we
couldn't reuse it should have brought my
golf club
are you upstairs
I know it's going to try something
it's being way too quiet
I thought you're gonna pull one on me
not happening that's so cool
I can't believe it
why'd they let this go this is recent so
I was I was here like a year and a half
ago right because for the building now
it's been burned down someone burned it
down what
you can smell it it looks like a recent
fire it's crazy
good place
oh can't wait to ride all the rides
[Music]
I know the date spot Chris has taken me
too
whoa what a [__] dude you holy [__] I
was not ready for that I'm gonna show
the view in a second just go into a
better spot here come the view
sane oh it doesn't I feel like oh
actually oh sorry what's the time cold
oh it is the anime that's one of the
coolest views I've seen
you you didn't hype this up for me
you're just like seeing a whole city in
mountains that's so pretty
just filming this for my own safety down
here son I don't know where he's taking
me
oh my god this is my last vlog
what is still there
what have we got here this is
why are you making me go first whoa
this is good old Buddha
I'll take that why is it here exactly
who put it here that's bizarre right
yeah
why is it
Ah that's confusing yeah wait no stop it
you dig in your own grave craze
what
crates they look like a quest item is up
there you gotta break the crate somehow
but first you have to yeah you
yeah okay
insane I can't get over it
and here's your accommodation for
tonight oh thanks well watch out you
said it was a five-star reviewcast
all right I commissioned Chris to take
over
[Music]
we're gonna roll it down
and the whole city will Splash a little
faster please all right you ready
roll it there ready three two one
come on come on
that's pretty good get ready
[Music]
come on come on hey
for me
an entire Village just got wiped out by
a stable in a couple
how did it start
[Music]
we're right at the ryokin it's seven now
so it's dark
it's really pretty
cool place
gonna have some dinner and some Onsen
just chill
abandoned building number four
is it Chris was trying to break into the
machine
we got all the old flavors
good old Bicky what's your favorite
my favorite J1 CC lemon
because you get 33 lemons worth of
vitamin C in every Camp okay well that
one's Still Still thriving sir
check this out
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
we are at an old Samurai Village
you get a feel of how it used to be
it's really cool cool shots
so bright though I can't see anything
we got the penis man as well on the
right
foreign
[Music]
should I go first yeah
[Laughter]
I'm sliding like this
oh God there's more oh no
going then
show them how it's done
that's not bad actually
damn
you can make tick tocks out of it
damn that's a steep almost someone's
embarrassing dad stop it look at these
losers taking this no one's taking the
stair
you were saying they used to be an old
school of some right here yeah was that
here on the escalator they studied right
here we're just like the samurai
I like
thank you well I just like this
a strange Buddhist temple that's strange
designated important cultural asset just
like Felix thank you so this is a gift
from Mussolini because he liked the
story of the Samurai
is that correct Rome donation Monument
so the legend goes 14 to 17 year old
Samurai saw fire and they thought they
had lost or been invaded or something
he's the best historian basically they
committed Supergirl because they thought
they had lost
but they didn't it was just a fire
damn that is so crazy looking
what kind of filthy but you can go
inside they took the plans from da Vinci
no you said that that was what you said
DaVinci built a structure in France that
had this sort of architecture and they
were like oh that's cool we'll do that
yeah I think they brought it to Japan or
they saw it and they're like that's
pretty good let's do that
[Music]
do you ever think they went a little bit
overboard on the stickers
that makes it Charming the way down is
over there right we'll come down a
different way in a minute what oh they
go Andrew what it says firing under each
other Helix
whoa that's so cool and then you go over
the top and you just go over the top and
you go that's so cool
whoa
look at these trees
they must be so old look how big they go
[Laughter]
[Music]
why don't we ordered calories that is
ridiculous
[Music]
just got back in Tokyo such a nice ride
really nice trip had a really good time
can't wait to see Mercy in the puggies
there damn
Kroger's pretty [__] cold too
you forget left Tokyo for two days and
I'm like whoa everything's big
[Music]
today is a very very special day eggy's
birthday no I don't believe it
[Music]
Iggy looks like no one showed up to his
birthday party
what the hell man you know a legend once
wore the head
and now it's passed on to you it's the
silence wow
your turn Momo
[Music]
oh my God oh my God
today you get as much as you wanted
[Music]
thank you
you're tired from all that food
huh you look tired we're all first
[Music]
it's a very spring-like day today so
we're going picnicking I'm the captain
[Music]
you having a good time
oh god look from mommy's repairing we
got onigiri we got my crazy hair in the
wind what you've made protein cookies
thank you
so good love it
good right let's try the onigiri oh you
put it on the outside so it's crispy
you excited eggy hello
they're so tired after that walk huh
[Music]
we're at Team labs they have a different
exhibition this time so I'm looking
forward to check it out
[Music]
I told Marzia there were alien eggs and
she looked at me like I was crazy
well well well
this was quite busy
it seems like everyone everyone has to
fight for a photo up
[Music]
that was really pretty but since we had
been there before all the tourists came
you can tell just like how much nicer it
was when it wasn't so full some places
it's like okay Enter okay now you leave
it's like oh I get it it's really cool
though still recommended
foreign
he bought a controller for an arcade and
I was like you can buy a controllers
like Google and they have it for my
favorite game and I think this might be
it
man
[Music]
I'm the first one to the arcade
absolutely no one here yet
gonna play my favorite
[Music]
it's so good to just get a couple
minutes in the arcade although it's so
much so now I'm heading back home gonna
do something else I really enjoy doing
it's a fun day it's a chill day it's a
Sunday all right assistant away today
actually that's why I'm doing all this
time
foreign
[Music]
did pretty good so difficult though like
I kind of brute force my way through a
lot of it like you look at the other
ones there they're not necessarily that
strong but it's so fun it's such a fun
workout I'm in Yokohama now
it's a really nice day and I'm gonna
head back home have some lunch
no dog diapers this time yeah
if you're too lazy to go to the arcade
make the arcade come to you this will be
a hell to set up but I'm very excited
what's up we got a bunch of wood in the
back we're building for Marzia and like
a closet office which I think is a
really good solution because monster
needs her desk but we also need space
for the baby so hopefully it'll be nice
[Music]
foreign
going to the hardware store get some
Nails hopefully we'll get Marcia's shelf
done and desk whatever it is it needs to
be done I can't believe how hot it is
it's only March right now I'm actually
going to UK next month but I want to
stay
[Music]
thank you
I'm in my zone Ikea mode
here I am minding my own business did
you get a bath mama
they want me to give you a bag
what
[Music]
gonna miss you guys we're leaving
I've never been to this station before
it's kind of cool we're getting
shinkansen tickets no car this time so
yeah we're going to Osaka to go to usj
like Universal for Nintendo Land we
wanted to go for a while but since Maya
was sick we didn't want to leave them
Now's the Time I'm excited to ride the
shinkansen it's only like two and a half
hours I can't believe how fast it is
foreign
[Music]
just walking through the hotel should be
a couple minutes it's a little colder
here that is cool
I love the answer oh that's what it
actually is okay well the front is cool
hey
nice and cozy
I almost keep it so warm
God damn maybe you like it yeah I knew
you would like that
[Music]
what was that
oh thank you very amazed
[Music]
thank you
these ants are [__] nut that's a
roller coaster what there he is
gotta do notorious and stuff right
you pay the price though that damn is
busy
[Music]
that's really pretty
it's like Japanese where's Waldo
be a giant they really go all out here
what do you think kind of food they have
damn the lines to eat at these places
are crazy
this place is mad I think it was raining
when we were in last time so we didn't
really feel like
what is
going on
[Music]
why does it look like that
Alsina definitely has that grungy vibe
to it
no no
you're gonna leave without me
vegetarian look at that
foreign
[Music]
anything else we're going to Nintendo
Land now well we're going to usj which
is Universal Studios we don't have the
pre-entry ticket
I'm a little concerned about him
otherwise we can almost go in the Spy
family right
yeah such a cool station
[Music]
and now please enjoy the rest of your
stay at Universal Studios
[Music]
do I look good in this
really cute
I tip my hair through all the other
Luigi's they don't seem to care that we
start at zero points
I didn't even hit the plan
foreign
[Music]
but we only get one that's fine
thank you
[Music]
so we didn't win the Nintendo tickets
but we did get two sharks
so who's the real winner here honestly
it kind of sucks
we'll figure out
[Music]
we're queuing up for butterbeer the line
is just
never had it
it's good
foreign
[Music]
that's pretty good I like it actually
damn look at the castle
where's you here saying we're in UK
ain't it
for uh
nah that's too long for Luigi or as I
would like to say
[Music]
I don't know if it's a red day or
something
but we didn't expect it to be this busy
we should check out a ride then
[Music]
but I'm not allowed to film so
it's kind of weird
oh my God
track
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so aesthetic
oh man you're gonna watch this in the
edit and you're gonna be like whoa this
hotel room is so big
someone's face
just
this is the smallest attack I've ever
visited today we're going to Nara it
should be really fun I love going there
it's really pretty and they got the
crazy deers
notice anything different about me
the mask mandate is over
most people are still wearing a mask
we're leaving us again
you've been great but I really look for
an hour
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
can I get some
food
we found a veggie meatball place I'll be
the judge
love the entry
[Music]
we're gonna check out Nora Dreamland
but we think they bulldozed it down it's
an old abandoned theme park and it looks
amazing I don't know why they have to
tear them down we'll go and check it out
anyway but I don't think it'll be there
but that's not the reason we came to
Nile so it's fine
[Music]
oh
I keep saying to Marseille it's like
Swedish summer whenever it's hot
might be even be hotter we're checking
out the park now and maybe meeting some
deers make some new friends it's so
pretty here I love Nara look at that
Pagoda I mean I didn't even see it
man he's just vibing looks like me when
I wake up my face is all like puffy no
offense of course
I'm gonna go say hi yeah I think the
temple is closed
I remember we could enter last time
wow
[Music]
that's like it's the coolest Temple ever
it's fun with the deers and all but now
it's just so unreal
[Music]
like
all right what do we got
hey good fortune that's a good fortune
they look so incredible
like all the details
and then like another amazing one next
to it
Sunny housing just seeing a building can
make you happy
did we pass the vibe check
hi guys we don't have food sorry
it's so funny they've been taught to
like bow before they get the food
it begins do you want to give one
are they nice
you have the funniest bounce dude okay
fine
[Music]
what are you doing
it's not for you
[Music]
I love it here it makes me so happy yeah
we're going to check out the even better
Temple
yeah I think I recognize it at least but
I don't know if that's because I just
copied it from Minecraft
is that the face
they have to steal his mouth
[Music]
so annoying when fans recognize you and
they just start following you and you
think
you think they don't notice
that they're following you
but I can notice
I know what you're doing yeah try and
play it on me and myself memories of
being here we're so puzzled here's the
bigger one
because we were like I swear you could
enter
they had a big Temple and then they were
like let's make a bigger one
that has to be the best Temple ever
it's so insane can you imagine how
pretty if it was in bloom
[Music]
yeah they just saw my Minecraft world
and they copied it they did a pretty
good job I think
oh my goodness that's a big Buddha
that was steps though God damn oh damn
with the light coming through that looks
so good
[Laughter]
we wrote for baby and he understood it
was for a child so I think they're gonna
do a special riding for it it was a tile
so he'll be in the room for chilling for
the repair if they need it
so that's for delivery
and that's for children I'll get them
for you
[Music]
so we got these based on our names
what's yours truth
I'm rich great smart Sky happy I think
so we
got so many gifts
they gave this to everyone that was
very Japanese in in a good way they just
kept giving us gifts we just wanted to
paint they were like the check is coming
we're like okay
that was really funny anyway we're
really tired
so we're just gonna head back and chill
and then tomorrow we're going to
hamamatsu maybe we'll spend this lucky
coin
[Music]
we're gonna go to a place Marty really
wanted to see it's like a forest so
we'll start by checking that out
I booked the car rental for the wrong
station like hamatsucho or something
instead of Panama Matsu there's hamamata
Castle
looking tiny
it's cute though but we're taking the
bus first so
[Music]
now we feel like we're in the nitty
grating when you're taking the bus for
40 minutes and I don't know where we are
there's always a Family Mart so you're
always safe
it's close
[Music]
it actually looked like you were running
I was looking at the phone
I'm just used to running so slowly
all right we're finally back
took an hour we're going with our plan B
they're just about to close so I don't
even know if we can do our plan B this
is really pretty
oh what
a guy
dude it's just that ghost of sushima I
had the Hat
I unlocked it
and then the coffee go so sushima
sounds so creepy
[Music]
oh
oh yeah the aubergine
oh they have the best instrument
yes I had one of these
[Music]
foreign
guys
I picked this up at the music museum
this is the first time I'm gonna try it
it smells good
it's so weird blowing from your nose
because it comes like through your mouth
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
sounds horrible honestly
thank you
it's good
[Music]